y ha dicho repetidamente que esta cumbre
plantea un desafío adicional porque las
condiciones de pandemia no pueden
garantizar una participación equitativa
de la sociedad civil que tanto será esa
afectación y porque impedirá un mejor
desarrollo de la cob 26
hola angela muchas gracias por
recibirnos y totalmente de acuerdo con
esto que estás planteando en la pandemia
y las condiciones ya estructurales de
acceso a estos espacios de toma de
decisiones cómo son las cosas que son
sumamente restrictivas para las personas
del sur global y todavía más para las
personas que están en la primera línea
con el cambio climático lo que siempre
es pues súper difícil no de de saltar
como lo son las visas los costes de
financiamiento los permisos laborales
etcétera tienen un nuevo nivel de
complejidad en el marco de la pandemia
de las restricciones que impone el
gobierno de inglaterra para el ingreso y
en la movilización de las personas en el
marco de la cop 26 usted es
representante juvenil de su país y los
jóvenes han manifestado desde hace meses
que más pueden hacer ahora para obligar
a los líderes políticos y también al
sector privado a actuar
bueno en primer lugar yo creo que es
vital que los jóvenes estemos presentes
en la con 26 y particularmente aquellos
que pertenecemos a los países del sur
global y con especial con con claramente
en nuestra región en américa latina y el
caribe por eso es necesario que se
movilicen financiamientos para que
podamos estar allí
y para que también nuestras voces sean
escuchadas después en segundo lugar yo
creo que desde la juventud y también
desde la sociedad civil quienes no
participamos directamente de las
negociaciones ya que no tenemos la
potestad de hacerlo tenemos que incidir
de forma política lo lo que es conocido
como lobby para generar el sentido común
de la urgencia de la crisis de la que
estamos viviendo un ejemplo súper claro
es en 2009 se prometieron 100 billones o
en español 100 mil millones de dólares
al año a partir de 2020 para
financiamiento de medidas de mitigación
y adaptación al cambio climático y hoy
en día aún no hemos alcanzado esa meta
esto es uno de los grandes objetivos de
esta cop y es algo que se espera con un
montón de expectativa pero no podemos
quedarnos en los 100 mil millones
tenemos cierto había más allá la crisis
climática ya se encuentra entre nosotros
y los costes de no afrontar la van a ser
muchísimo mayores que los costes de
tratar de adaptarnos y de mitigar los
efectos bueno aquí se ve claramente uno
de los objetivos pero además adicionales
de eso cuál es su llamado como parte
civil en representación de la argentina
para está con 26
bueno como joven latinoamericana el
primer son a miento es a promover
mecanismos de inclusividad destacó el
presidente
albox armas comentó que iba a ser blanco
más inclusiva de todas y al día de hoy a
menos de una semana de que empiece
estamos ante una de las copas menos
inclusivas de todas de nuevo los temas
revisados los temas de costes de las
últimas seis con cinco se hicieron en
europa como podemos asegurar la
inclusividad de la representatividad de
las y los jóvenes de todo el mundo si se
siguen haciendo en una misma región y en
segundo lugar en concreto desde
argentina hay una postura bastante
consensuada desde la sociedad civil es
que queremos alternativas novedosas de
financiamiento para la acción climática
como por ejemplo desde el gobierno de la
argentina se propone el canje de deuda
por acción climática pero no solamente
queremos de esto queremos que se
trabajen otros mecanismos por fuera de
las transferencias directas para poder
enfrentar esta crisis y también para
poder financiar el desarrollo sostenible